Ellen Stevenson ist überzeugter Trump
Wähler das Sturmgewehr hat er sich in
der Wahl nach beschafft als Präsident
Trump abgewählt wurde aus Angst Joe
Biden würde es verbieten warum sein
Präsident zur Zielscheibe der Justiz
wird für ihn ganz klar
es ist eine unverhohlene politische
Verfolgung die Führung der Demokraten
wollte Trump immer schon kriegen
und das ist der Versuch eines
aktivistischen Richters Trump wegen
irgendetwas festzunageln weil es ihn
nicht gefällt dass er wieder zur Wahl
antritt und ihr gewinnen könnte
werden die Republikaner weiter zu Trump
halten trotz Anklage der 30-Jährige ist
überzeugt sie kommt zu einem Präsidenten
sogar gelegen
das ist eine der besten kostenlosen
Werbekampagnen die er je bekommen hat
die Berichterstattung ist gut für sein
Wahlkampf sie macht ihn noch populärer
Trumps Reise nach New York City ein
riesiges öffentliches Spektakel er ist
der erste Ex-Präsident der angeklagt
wird ein historischer Auftritt die
Anklage Fälschung von
Geschäftsunterlagen in 34 Fällen so
sollte kriminelles Verhalten verborgen
werden Trump sieht das anders plädiert
auf nicht schuldig in einem
Exklusiv-Interview mit Fox News spricht
Trump erstmals über die Anklage
es war ein trauriger Tag aber auch ein
wunderbarer Tag meine Umfragewerte sind
durch die Decke gegangen die Menschen
haben es verstanden
wenn Sie in diesem Fall in New York
verurteilt werden würden sie aus dem
Rennen ums Weiße Haus aussteigen nein
niemals das ist nicht mein Ding
die Anklage platzt mitten in den
Wahlkampf für die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur der
Republikaner aber statt den anzugreifen
allen ihm selbst seine härtesten
parteiinternen Konkurrenten zu Hilfe
experten sehen das als ganz typisches
Phänomen dem Anführer die Stange halten
wenn er angegriffen wird es bleibt ihnen
auch nichts anderes übrig denn die
Mehrheit der Republikaner steht hinter
Trump mehr als 90% halten die Anklage
für politisch motiviert
keiner von ihnen schafft es klar zu
machen warum genau er der Kandidat der
Republikaner sein sollte sie sind immer
noch so auf Donald Trump fixiert was vor
allem daran liegt dass die Basis hinter
ihm steht die anderen haben keinen Draht
zur Basis können keine Alternative zu
ihm bieten
Trump führt derzeit in den Umfragen ist
aber nicht der einzige der bei den
republikanischen Wählern beliebt ist
hier in Midland Michigan läuft sich
Trumps größter Rivale ronde Säntis warm
der Gouverneur von Florida ist Ehrengast
beim frühlingsfrühstück der lokalen
Republikaner für seine Fans gilt kein
händisch schütteln keine selfies für uns
Journalisten keine Interviews keine
Frage der 44-Jährige gilt für viele als
neuer Hoffnungsträger jung smart und
erzkonservativ
er hat sich ganz dem Kulturkampf
verschrieben Verband Bücher über
Rassismus verbietet den Grundschulen
über Gender und sexuelle Orientierung zu
sprechen
Eltern im ganzen Land sollten in der
Lage sein ihre Kinder in die Grundschule
zu schicken ohne dass man ihnen
irgendeine Agenda aufzwingt ohne dass
ein Lehrer einem Schüler sagt dass er
vielleicht im falschen Körper geboren
wurde oder dass er ein Geschlecht wählen
kann
das gehört sich nicht
seine Kandidatur hat er noch nicht
offiziell verkündet auch wenn alles
danach klingt
wir müssen stark sein die Linie halten
und niemals nachgeben wir haben in
Florida viel erreicht aber ich sage eins
ich habe den Kampf erst begonnen
unter Republikanern klar hinter Trump
seit der Anklage ist er noch weiter
abgeschlagen die 33-Jährige Managerin
Tiffany Hauser würde beiden Kandidaten
ihre Stimme geben
wir müssen allerdings danach gehen wer
gewinnen kann und das ist ronde Säntis
ich denke Trump wird nur für viel
Ablenkung sorgen
Ron ist der richtige Mann für den
Jobs könnte vor allem dann eine
Alternative werden wenn noch weitere
Anklagen gegen Trump erhoben werden
das könnte vor allem in diesen Fällen
passieren
die Geheimdokumente auf Trumps Anwesen
Mario der Angriff auf us-kapitol am 6
januar und die mögliche
Wahlbeeinflussung im Bundesstaat Georgia
hätte ein mehrfach Angeklagter Trump
überhaupt noch Chancen im Rennen um die
Präsidentschaft
mehrere Anklagen und all die anderen
Dinge die wir über Donald Trump wissen
könnten und zwar bei den Vorwahlen die
Unterstützung der Republikaner bescheren
aber ihn bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen
unwählbar machen
Trumps Basis wie hier im ländlichen
Virginia hält weiter treu zu ihm seit
der Anklage erst recht
sie sind der harte Kern der bei den
parteiinternen Vorwahlen Trump wählt sie
beten für ihren Präsidenten Gewalt
würden sie für ihn aber auf keinen Fall
anwenden das friedliche Miteinander ist
ihnen wichtiger
wenn wir nicht mehr mit unseren Nachbarn
sprechen können die andere politische
Ansichten haben wenn wir uns nicht in
unserer Liebe zu diesem Land vereinen
können dann ist es vorbei dann werden
wir uns zerfleischen denn gern
Ellen Stevenson und seine Frau Emily
wünschen sich von der Politik weniger
Hahnenkämpfe mehr Fokus auf die
Bedürfnisse der Menschen
der Durchschnitt Amerikaner interessiert
sich nicht für Kulturkampf und den
politischen Kram es geht eher um Themen
die man am Küchentisch bespricht wie
viel es zum Beispiel kostet ein Huhn zu
füttern
für ihn wäre Donald Trump der richtige
im Weißen Haus auch als verurteilter
Straftäter die Mehrheit der Amerikaner
sieht das anders die Anklage gegen Trump
sie spaltet das Land einmal mehr